[Music]
you know coach uh and kevin have both
been candid with ben in terms of uh
you know letting him know that the
current contract structure is not gonna
work and so we're gonna have to figure
out if we can work together to you know
to craft something that that we all can
live with
that's art rooney the second owner of
the pittsburgh steelers addressing the
elephant in the room
41.25 million dollar cap number for the
final year of ben roethlisberger's
contract ben rothsberger in response to
what rooney said made it clear that
he'll do everything he can made that
clear to them from the very beginning it
was my idea to basically help the team
however i can this year i don't care
about my pay at all this year i'm pretty
sure i want to go one more year because
i think i can do it and give us a real
chance
of winning so peter it's a simple simple
formula you take what he's do to make
this year you reduce his salary down to
the minimum which is a hair over a
million dollars for his level of
experience you turn the rest into a
guaranteed payment and you figure out
how many years you want to spread it
over the more you spread it the lower
the cap number comes because those cap
dollars go into future years you're
going to have to pay the piper at some
point but you don't have to carry 41.25
million
in the year where the cap is going to
drop and it still may stay low for a
couple of years after this but at least
you're spreading it out and you're not
taking the hit now and that's money that
the steelers can use on other players
that they desperately need so this tells
me
they've found a way to work together for
one more year
but then the question becomes does one
more year become two is 2021 the
farewell tour for ben roethlisberger
mike i mean what the steelers
i assume have done
is they have said you know we think
we're closer
to the 11-0 steelers that started the
season
we think we're closer to that team than
the one in five team that ended the
season
i'm not so sure
and especially when
you've got the browns being better
and joe burrow you would think
would be playing for 16 games next year
nothing's guaranteed
but
the bengals are not going to be
pushovers for much longer they're not
going to be great
but
they they split with the steelers this
year
i bet they split with the steelers next
year
but but anyway the whole point i'm
making is that the steelers i think are
taking a gamble
and the gamble is that the guy who
looked old and slow
down the stretch of this season
and couldn't move very very much
down the stretch is you know everybody
says well brady's a statue brady can get
out of trouble okay
ben roethlisberger is like
a classic old time pocket quarterback
and don't ask me to do anything else
and that's an exaggeration obviously but
that is how he looked at the end of the
season it's why if i was tomlin i was
rooney i wouldn't just say hey let's
make a deal i would also say listen come
back 15 pounds lighter next year
i i mean that's what i would say to him
he just looks like he's too heavy
for that for that position and i'm sure
he and and the pro roethlisberger people
would say hey this is how he's been
forever this time but you know you've
got to look at where you are in life
right now and where you are in life is
at the end and you've got to do stuff to
preserve
greatness
or or to reinstitute greatness and to me
i think he's got to look at his physical
self in this offseason and come back
better and in better shape in uh in july
and august
yeah and he hasn't said that publicly as
part of what he said yesterday but
that's a key aspect of it because
otherwise you're just kicking the can
and i agree with you i don't think the
steelers automatically show up next year
and have the same kind of of performance
that they had even when they were
winning games other than blowing out the
browns and the bengals at home it's not
like you can point to a bunch of
signature impressive wins over great
teams you know they caught the ravens
once when they didn't have anybody and
that's when the steelers were kind of
fizzling out at the end of their
unbeaten string they got the ravens they
gained the 14. grossly yeah grossly but
the game where they won in baltimore the
ravens grossly outplayed them the
steelers just were able to bend lady
luck in their direction so this is a
team you got james connor who's going to
become a free agent not that he's the
next frank o'haras for them by any means
but they got to address the tailback
position you've got juju smith schuster
who's going to be a free agent what are
you going to do about that you got
marquis pouncey reportedly looking at
retiring what are you going to do about
that i just feel like there's an element
of
after a relationship that's lasted this
long no one wants to be the one who says
let's end it ben doesn't want to walk
away and the steelers don't want to push
him so all right let's just let's kick
the can one more year and when you got a
coach who never has to worry about being
fired because you know the steelers
claim to fame is we've had three coaches
since 1969. it's not like mike tomlin's
saying
can i get a new quarterback please
because this guy's going to get me fired
if we come out and we go 6 and 10 this
year so that the problem they have peter
they better have a plan beyond 2021 or
they're going to get left in the dust in
that division with lamar jackson and
baker mayfield and joe burrow they
better have a quarterback they went 20
years between bradshaw and
roethlisberger and the defense helped
them stay relevant they better have a
quarterback because in this nfl if you
don't you are going to be a team that
six and 10 at best every year
i think you got to look at the tape of
the mason rudolph game you know when he
played uh you know the game he played
against cleveland and he played well in
that game and you have to decide if that
is enough to prevent you from being
in the first round quarterback business
this year if i were the steelers
unquestionably i would take a quarter if
they have a quarterback rated high
enough i'd take them with my pick in the
first round now the first round is going
to be crazy
because of all the quarterback movement
in this offseason you know who knows
could jared goff be available on draft
day
for a two or something you just you just
have no idea so there's a lot of things
that are going to be changing this off
season but if i'm the steelers
i do not exit draft weekend
with
the quarterback depth chart being
one roethlisberger two
um you know mason rudolph three dwayne
haskins
i just i wouldn't do that i don't know
what they'll do but we'll see
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports